[Música]
a quien de ustedes les gusta leer
levanten la mano
se acuerdan de su primer libro espero
que sí porque yo tengo una anécdota un
poco decepcionante sobre mi primer libro
yo descubrí los libros gracias a matilda
se acuerdan de matilda esta niña que
podía mover las cosas a mí lo que me
impresionaba de ella era que podía
devorar un libro tras otro yo decía yo
quiero ser como ella yo quiero ser como
como matilde y poder leer un libro tras
otro pero en mi casa pues no había
libros ninguno solamente teníamos una
enciclopedia porque se acuerdan antes de
internet no había cómo hacer las tareas
ok entonces la enciclopedia en esa
enciclopedia que teníamos había varios
cuentos como caperucita roja
pulgarcito así que yo me escondía en mi
closet porque tenía un closet super
grande y me ponía a leer
caperucita roja
lo que pasó después fue que yo ya estaba
cansada de leer cuentos y quería un
libro un libro de verdad así que mis
papás me llevaron a comprar un libro y
ese libro fue cinco semanas en globo de
julio verne
este libro yo estaba súper emocionada
saben llegué a mi casa
emocionadísima para leerlo
justo lo empiezo y no le entendía nada
absolutamente nada me decepcione mucho
de mí misma fue como ok creo que no
puedo ser matilda no puedo ser una
lectora como ella me olvidé de los
libros porque dije esto no es lo mío
paso el tiempo
crecí llegué a la preparatoria y en la
preparatoria no sé si a ustedes también
les tocó tuve clase de literatura
mi maestra me da pena decir pero mi
maestra pues no me motivaba mucho al
leer simplemente era como ahí está estos
capítulos de este libro léalo porque el
viernes les voy a poner 5 preguntas como
examen
yo así de que ok
y uno es un libro será el principito de
seguro lo conocen es un libro tan corto
tan corto y tan bello pero yo a los 15
años fue como
no no pude no pude no pude no sé cómo le
dice que pase la escuela pase la clase
de literatura pero no leí el principito
saliendo de la preparatoria mi mejor
amiga platicando yo con ella por
teléfono antes de que existiera whatsapp
digo no estoy tan vieja pero también
existía whatsapp en ese entonces
entonces mi mejor amiga me estaba
platicando sobre un libro ella me había
regalado un libro pero la verdad era uno
como de autoayuda se llamaba la princesa
que creía en los cuentos de hadas
trataba de una chica que se lleva a la
universidad y conocí a un hombre súper
guapo que era el príncipe pero
lamentablemente en cuanto se casó con
ella pues el tipo se volvió medio ogro
medio malo en fin es un libro de
autoayuda pero me tardé un año en leerlo
un año
entonces mi mejor amiga me está contando
sobre un libro que estaba leyendo
y
me hablaba de él con tanta emoción que
dije quiero leer ese libro quiero saber
porque mi mejor amiga está tan
emocionada con este libro
y les voy a decir que libro era pero sé
que me van a juzgar y se van a burlar de
mí pero era crepúsculo no
lo sé lo sé lo sé en fin mi mejor amiga
me hablaba tan emocionada que dije lo
quiero fui me lo compré y adivinen en
cuántos días me lo termine
me lo termine en dos días yo no paraba
de leer me llevaba el libro a todos
lados al baño a la cocina a todos lados
me lo llevaba y lo termina en dos días y
ya de ahí empecé a seguir leyendo porque
me gustó tanto la experiencia que quise
seguir leyendo mi mejor amiga me me
seguía recomendando libros pero no se
sentí que ya a sus gustos con los míos
no eran los mismos así que pues intenté
leer libros pero ninguno me volvía a
cautivar tanto como ese libro no pasó el
tiempo y estaba en internet ya existía
youtube entonces estaba navegando en
youtube viendo vídeos y me topé con una
chica de españa' que mostraba sus libros
no tienen idea de la cantidad de libros
que tenía esta niña o sea eran
impresionantes y tenía como 30 vídeos
donde mostraba los libros que había
comprado que le habían llegado
y esa misma noche los vi los 30 esa
noche no dormí fue como impresionante
bajó y le digo mis papás
acabo de ver una chica de españa' que
les regalan libros
y yo así que yo también quiero que me
regalen libros
y mi papá y como le hace y ya le explicó
que la chica tiene un blog donde escribe
las reseñas de cada libro y mi papá es
hazlo y yo ok pero mi papá se refería al
blog no no hagan vídeos en youtube
entonces pues bueno comencé subiendo mis
vídeos a youtube agarré la cámara que
había en mi casa la verdad no era una
cámara tan buena pero funcionaba y ya me
grabé empecé a hablar de los poquitos
libros que tenía me acuerdo que en ese
entonces tenía unos 5 o 6
y
lo subí
los borré porque porque me daba tanto
miedo que un familiar o un conocido me
viera en internet me viera hablando yo
sola frente a una cámara
es como que medio de locos no en ese
entonces en el 2015 era como no
hasta que poco a poco me animé y ahí los
dejé
y no pasó nada yo seguía y seguía tenía
unas cuantas visitas unos cuantos
comentarios pero de hecho cuando yo vi
el canal de esta chica de españa' ya se
imaginarán la lista de libros que quería
comprar porque esta niña me hablaba tan
emocionada de los libros que había leído
que yo dije yo quiero ss ss uno de ellos
serán los juegos del hambre entonces voy
corriendo con mi mejor amiga y le digo
ahora yo te voy a recomendar un libro yo
toda fregona no de que ahora yo y ya le
digo y me dice
porque si te gustó los juegos del hambre
porque no lees 1984
y yo es que no
no es un clásico es un poco difícil
porque porque yo le tenía miedo a los
clásicos le tenía miedo por julio verne
porque a los 12 años no pude leer cinco
semanas en globo fue como no no puedo no
puedo total seguí con eso
y poco a poco que iba yo subiendo vídeos
hablando de libros y me empecé a exigir
un poquito más ya no me llenaban estos
libros juveniles estos libros de
distopías
de de fantasía todo eso no yo quería
algo más y fue cuando empecé a leer
'orgullo y prejuicio' los miserables
todos esos libros a los cuales yo les
tenía un miedo me di cuenta que no son
tan malos que no son
tan intimidante como a los 12 años
pensaba entonces yo creo que los libros
llegan a ti en el momento justo y si
llego y no no lo entendiste no quiere
decir que no eres lector simplemente no
ha llegado ese libro que es para ti en
cuanto a lo de mis vídeos pues bueno ya
saben que nadie sabía de mis vídeos no
pero de repente pues mi vecina que tenía
unos 15 años más o menos va con mis
papás y les dice quiero ver a mariana mi
papá así está arriba para que la quieres
le dices qué
vi sus vídeos y quiero que me prestes
libros quiero quiero hablar con ella de
los libros mis papás
como como que vídeos a ver si subió unos
vídeos en internet mi papá mi papá
estaba de que super asustado de que de
qué están hablando y pues ya les ponen
los vídeos y ya me ven mi papá eso es
todo lo que estás haciendo o sea por qué
porque me habían encerrado en mi
habitación y no sabían absolutamente qué
hacía y era eso me la pasaba leyendo me
la pasaba grabando vídeos porque porque
llegue un momento en el lector que
quiera hablar con las personas del libro
que leyó quiere compartir un poquito su
experiencia y también como que te
cuenten los demás sobre los libros que
leyeron entonces yo creo que youtube
para mí fue una plataforma que me ayudó
muchísimo a poder conocer los libros
también porque en matilda si me hablaban
de libros pero me hablaban de libros
clásicos de clásicos que yo no me sentía
preparada hay personas que pueden leer
un clásico sin haber leído juveniles
y se me hace una una cosa maravillosa
pero también yo me sentía un poco
intimidada por ellos hasta que me di
cuenta que no los libros son tus amigos
de hecho el narrador de matilda dice los
libros le dijeron a matilda no estás
sola eso fue algo súper bonito de hecho
en el viaje que hice para acá me
acompaña un libro el asiento de mi lado
estaba solo y puse mi libro y no lo leí
porque estaba muy cansada pero pero ahí
va en mi libro conmigo no en fin
el asunto aquí es que yo creo que
debemos de darle una oportunidad a los
libros muchas veces pensamos que no nos
gusta me topado con muchas personas que
me dicen es que a mí no me gusta leer
pero tan emocionado sobre este libro
que me lo compré y me gustó y de ahí
hasta ellos me recomiendan de oros
entonces es algo muy muy muy maravilloso
lo que los libros nos transmiten más que
nada porque muchos dicen que la
literatura juvenil no es dos son libros
buenos pero sí lo son digo ya depende de
cada quien que lo ruiz zafón dicen que
los libros son espejos uno ve lo que uno
lleva adentro y yo creo que eso es muy
cierto porque de seguro les pasa que el
en un libro y le empieza en una cosa y
luego leer a alguien más y te encuentras
cosas que tú no te diste cuenta
el cantante enemigos dijo que cuando el
año 1984 lo leyó así hice un poco la
historia
política en lo político después lo volví
a leer y se enfocó en la historia de
amor en mi caso
después de mi conversión mi mejor amiga
me enfoqué en la historia de amor
obviamente pero yo creo que eso es lo
importante le entienda es una cosa o le
entienda es otra los libros están ahí
para ti para ayudarte para rescatarte yo
la verdad comencé mi canal en youtube
justo cuando me despidieron de mi primer
trabajo hubo un recorte de personal y yo
tuve que puedes irme
y yo me acuerdo mucho que con lo que me
pagaban yo llegaba a la librería a
comprarme dos libros cada quincena pero
no tenía tiempo para leerlos porque pues
ya saben el trabajo uno sale muy cansado
y quiere solamente dormir o ver a tus
amigos y no tenía tiempo para leer no
tenía me despiden que la verdad ya lo
puedo decir sin llorar porque en ese
entonces sí sí me pegó entonces me
despiden
y ya no tenía nada que hacer obviamente
estaba buscando trabajo pero había como
que una crisis laboral que nadie me
quería contratar porque no tenía
experiencia entonces pues bueno bill el
montón de libros que había comprado
y empecé a leerlos empecé a leerlos
los leía dos tres veces porque ya no
tenía dinero para comprar más y tenía
mucho mucho tiempo libre y fue cuando yo
bajaba con mis papás a contarles sobre
el libro que había leído y mis papás ok
ya mis papás no se emocionaba no no
había ese ese feeling no de qué dices
hay ya le estoy contando a esa persona a
esa persona también lo quiere leer pero
pues entiendo que después yo empecé a
inculcarles a mis papás ese hábito de la
lectura y es algo que me tiene súper
orgullosa de mí que no los obligue y eso
es lo que hoy no hay que obligar a nadie
a leer
simplemente ves a la otra persona en mi
caso yo vi a matilda que estaba súper
feliz hoy a mi amiga que estaba feliz
leyendo este libro y como que una parte
de nosotros queríamos contagiarnos de
esa felicidad que provocan los libros
aunque bueno muchos no provocan tanta
felicidad a veces nos ponen a llorar o
nos ponen a pensar o nos ponen enojo nos
mejores enojo nos que esa palabra la
acabo de inventar verdad
enojados
en fin total por eso empecé mi canal en
youtube ustedes dirán para que para que
empieces un canal si le estás hablando
la cámara osea de todas maneras ni
siquiera estás nadie te está diciendo
nada en sí pero pues me gusta me gustaba
hablar de una cámara me gustaba como que
sacar ese sentimiento de que los libros
me transmitían y eso la verdad me ha
dado muchas cosas que jamás imaginé como
él estaba aquí ahorita con ustedes he
conocido muchísimas personas y conocidos
escritores hablar con un escritor es
algo que como lector
tienes que hacer una vez en tu vida
imagínense el miedo de los escritores tu
escribes tu historia y la entregas y en
el momento en que la entregas tu ya no
eres dueño de esas palabras porque
porque el lector entiende lo que va a
entender no lo que el escritor quiso
transmitir
algo que me movió mucho mi corazón fue
que mi primer libro aunque no lo leí fue
julio verne cinco semanas en globo
e investigando me di cuenta que fue la
primera novela que él escribió
aunque yo no haya leído ese libro por
primera vez ya después lo leí solo para
aclarar y me gustó mucho ya le entendí o
sea es que la verdad habla sobre cosas
muy de matemáticas científicas y pues yo
la verdad para física y todo eso pues no
pero ahora sí la entendía un poquito más
y
ya me quedé ya se me olvidó que estaba
diciendo
ya soy muy bueno en fin
dios
me dio un bloque vergallo bueno
un aplauso por qué
ya me acordé gracias por su buena vibra
ok entonces imagínense y él mandó su
manuscrito y lo rechazaron no querían su
manuscrito hasta que después se topó con
un conocido que tenía una librería buena
una editorial y ya le ayudó un poquito
le mandó su manuscrito y él empezó a
hacer las correcciones y julio verne fue
manos a la obra hago esas correcciones
que tú me acabas de decir y lo
publicaron entonces que te deja a ti
como lector
que todo lo que tú quieras lo puedes
lograr todo absolutamente todo si va a
haber obstáculos en el camino no crean
también subir vídeos a youtube cuesta
cuesta muchísimo exponerse y para que
las editoriales me voltearon a ver y me
enviaran libros paso uno o dos años para
que me invitarán a presentar escritores
también entonces si no me hubiera
atrevido a abrir un libro si no me
hubiera atrevido a subir un vídeo a
youtube hablando de libros
que hubiera sido de mí
atrévanse hagan lo que les guste si
quieren escribir si quieren leer si
quieren ser un científico lo que quieran
háganlo sin miedo a que los demás lo
rechacen o se burlen porque sé que hay
muchos lectores aquí que les gusta tal
vez 'crepúsculo' y no lo quieren admitir
yo la verdad después vi la película ya
más grande y fue que adiós pero bueno
tenía 18 años es válido no pero bueno
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]